[Music]
one - thank you for coming first of all
it's a great treat to be here main
purpose of this event is to celebrate
this year's entrant teams all 150 of
them and of course especially the seven
finalist teams who are here tonight to
share their plans with us before I get
started I'd like to give special thanks
to three groups of people first of all
the sponsors without whom this wouldn't
be possible and you saw a list of them
at the beginning as you walked in I'd
like to highlight two recent changes to
that list
the town of Haverhill has recently
agreed to provide incubator services to
the winning team in the competition and
something you'll hear a little bit more
about later in the evening is for the
last year we've been working on creating
an endowment fund for the competition to
make sure that it will be stable and
growing in the future and we'll talk a
little bit more about that as the
evening goes along second group is the
judges group of about 24 people
professionals from all walks of the
venture community life entrepreneurs
angel investors venture capitalists
professional service providers and
others who put in uncounted number of
hours reading all of those 150 entrants
and selecting among them 39
semi-finalists so semi-finalists came
here presented their full plans and from
those seven teams were selected last
week those seven are the teams you'll
hear tonight finally helping those teams
to perfect their plans and really
improve the quality year-over-year are a
large group of dedicated mentors who
dedicate their time and energy and
effort providing knowledge and
experience helping the teams out so -
all three of those groups thank you very
much
we couldn't be here without you just a
brief description about how we got to
this evening it's a it's a complicated
and winding road we started in the fall
in September we had a great kick off
speaker and Winblad talking about
software
entrepreneurship about a month later we
had the 1k entries we had 84 business
ideas submitted for consideration in
December we had the award ceremony where
we picked 10 winners ranging from
Internet to biotech hardware to medical
devices over the I ap the 50k organizing
team went to Singapore where we hosted a
workshop called the global startup
workshop we had about 140 participants
from four continents come to hear about
how to run a competition such as this
and how it fits in with the larger
entrepreneurial community a couple of
professors helped us out in that
endeavor ed Steinfeld flew to Singapore
with us and give a great speech and
Lester Thurow spoke by videoconference
in the spring we had Mitch Kapoor come
and give a great talk exhibiting his own
desire to see one of the entrant teams
in action the micro engine team creating
the miniature jet engine to power your
laptop computer and we'd like to see
that one too in February of course we
started the process all over again with
150 executive summaries coming in for
consideration those were cut down to 39
by the judges the 39 most promising
candidates Alex lots a recent MIT grad
from about 10 years ago founder of nbx
corporation spoke about his experience
with entrepreneurship and those teams
then went forward and spent the next
month and a half writing plans
perfecting them bringing us to where we
are today we'll hear from all those
teams and we'll hear who the winners
will be this is a completely student-run
organization every year we have a
management turnover it's a great
challenge and a great opportunity to
bring a new fresh blood to the to the
organization and we have a great team
identified for next year I'd like for
them to all stand up if possible so you
can see their faces and know who you'll
be working with next year we have
[Applause]
we often like to talk about the
successes of our alumni and in
particular the fact that although it may
seem like a cliche everyone who enters
is a winner many of the teams as you saw
over 42 companies have been founded in
ten years we've only had obviously ten
winners maybe eleven if you think about
last year but there have been plenty of
other teams that were not winners in the
competition but that had the commitment
the spirit the drive and the talent to
go forward and create successful
enterprises nonetheless so I'd like to
just talk a little bit about each of
these volunteer solutions one of last
year's co-winners has just recently
launched their volunteer database
matching site in Austin Boston Detroit
Los Angeles in Silicon Valley
direct hit technologies has closed their
second round of funding and they have
partnership deals with Lycos HotBot AOL
Apple Microsoft and others all in the
last 10 months Akamai Technologies has
built a worldwide content distribution
network and are currently working with
some of the top ten content sites on the
internet they were finalists last year
but not one of the winners and a semi
finalist last year frictionless commerce
has also recently closed closed funding
and been profiled in Boston magazine
finally from a previous year Virtua Inc
has just launched their product the
mimeo electronic whiteboard enhancement
so I'd like to I thank all these teams
for having the spirit to go forward and
really create companies not just
business plans and that's really what
this competition is all about and as you
saw in the presentation at the beginning
we've had over 40 companies and created
over 500 million dollars in value
reflecting the fact that we're here to
create companies not business plans so
with all that said I'd like to introduce
our keynote speaker for the evening dr.
Keenan Sahin dr. Sahin has a successful
record in academia business and
technology he's recently named the Ernst
& Young software technology entrepreneur
of the year he was a Sloan professor and
he has a PhD from MIT as well
his company was recently acquired by
Lucent Technologies and he's remaining
on as president of that division with
that said I'd like to introduce dr. king
[Applause]
that's a truly great honor and pleasure
to be here
a place where I spent a lifetime I came
here in 1961 fully intending to leave
MIT to go elsewhere fully intending to
leave Boston to go as far I tried I made
many attempts of escape never worked
they all work and I'm of course
absolutely delighted and today means a
great deal to me to be addressing you
for many reasons my one of my most
cherished papers as an undergraduate was
entrepreneurship and at the time I had
to struggle to learn the spelling of the
word and teach it to others because
people did not know what this thing was
what I change now it's in everybody's
lips one of the questions that might be
in your minds I'll anticipated it how
does it feel to be worth billion and a
half dollars
[Applause]
my answer to that is I really wouldn't
know and I genuinely mean it because I
really do not consider myself as owning
it simply as a custodian for it let me
elaborate there's an old sort of saying
a man is asked are you honest and he
says I don't know my honesty has never
been tried and I always said money
doesn't motivate me it is what money can
do that shapes my life
and one day if you're interested I'll
tell you a whole lot on how that notion
was applied to Keenan systems at any
rate I was tested actually tested on
that principle so I can confidently say
I was true to my words in February 1998
I got a call from Lucent they wanted to
meet and I said if this is about
investments please don't even bother
come we're very happy to be independent
and charting our course they insisted on
coming claiming that there were many
joint opportunities and when they asked
a group president for a private meeting
I knew what it was all about was
February and he said King we've done our
search everybody on the street Wall
Street is recommending this company and
I thought was written to know about us
and by answer was an immediate no very
privileged very honored that you thought
of us but the answer is no and I must
say he was startled because we both knew
more than billion dollars was on the
table and he was a man who owned hundred
percent of the company and he had no
hesitation in saying no and it was a
test of my own self that it wasn't the
money what the money could do and at
that time me being rich did not have any
meaning for the company and I've always
held that a person doesn't own a company
because companies people
and person owns a financial interest in
the company the fact that I had 100% did
not make me on road to people merely an
employee who had a lot of impact on the
company but I could have been employee
without ownership president of a company
I still could have had a lot of lot of
impact but what changed was five months
later inside of one week I had a meeting
with the key executives of British
Telecom
Telefonica and France Telecom and they
all informed me that our products had
been chosen as the corporate wide
technologies I must say while I was
having the meetings I was 10 feet tall
as soon as I left these meetings I
shrank to 5 feet tall so onerous
responsibility to have AT&T MCI Worldcom
quest level 3 France Telecom British
Telecom Telefonica
I can go on and on and on as your
clients and have a personal relationship
with their executives and know that your
mistakes will immediately impact them
and know that your accomplishments will
immediately contribute to their success
and that's when the Lucent offer all of
a sudden made sense
I said now there's a reason for the
merger and Lucent considered it in order
now JP Morgan was the investment bankers
and their chairman personally took the
case he was really intrigued he said
Keenan this is an amazing company 100%
growth year after year 50% margin no
stock options just a straight pay
exceptional hiring record how did this
happen
I said I don't know if you ask me I
probably come up with the story but I
myself don't know but JP after doing
their multiple analysis and so on came
up with three billion dollars
for the company as the market value if
you took loosens multiple and multiplied
it by our forward 12 months income they
think that's what it would have be and
my response to them was thank you I
appreciate your advice but you're not
coming to the negotiation table thank
you
I'll do it alone and it was a big
surprise because it was the head of M&A
that personally said I'd be happy to
call Richmond again I'll be happy to
call the executives that loosen after
all we know these guys were a while I
will get you a good deal but I said you
don't understand this is not about money
this is about what we killing systems
and Lucent candle together so four
months were spent negotiating the
intangibles
Keenen systems remaining a wholly owned
subsidiary and us having a mind share
table so it was bold it was audacious
during the announcement I told her the
staff I said there are two objectives
behind the merger one is to make a huge
impact on the software market two is to
transform Lucent and I'm very pleased to
say those seemed almost corny how could
a 750 person company no matter how many
Sloan graduates there are say we're
going to transform a hundred and thirty
six thousand company which has a history
of more than hundred years but I have to
tell you we have already traveled fast
down that path rich Megan was in town
last year like yesterday he talked our
Jordan he taught our vocabulary he
talked of Keenan systems models and he
said will and I asked him I said rich
what did you think of this before the
merger and after the merger said Kim
before the merger it was getting the
technology and during the due diligence
we discovered we had much much more than
that and now we're delighted
it is the models it is the business
practices and is how you guys have done
it and I want Lucent to learn from that
and emulate that I can't tell you how
happy our people are now they are
standing ten feet tall
now how about me personally well I
genuinely mean it when I say I merely
consider myself custodian of that worth
to be applied to very productive useful
purposes my real excitement is my role
inside the suit I have two roles one is
to continue as the president of Kenan
systems which I cherish especially
interactions with all the wonderful
people both from Sloan rest of MIT in
Harvard and Princeton and Yale you name
it we've hired them but much more
importantly as vice president of
software technology at Bell Labs when
that was told to me that I would be the
vice president of software technology
idle didn't pay much attention to it
because you know I've done a lot of work
for the financial institutions when you
go to a bank
everyone's a vice president you wonder
how these vice presidents get together
and every meeting with the president so
I didn't pay much attention the white
turns out that labs which has 1,200 core
researchers equivalent to academics they
would be professors and assistant
professors and so on if they were in
academic institutions 5,000 core people
could do fundamental work 20,000 people
spread into the businesses all told
about 25,000 people and for all that
there are eight vice presidents and I'm
very thrilled very pleased very happy to
be one of them not only that no one
asked our software and I have been given
these honors and exciting
responsibilities to impact by labs and
loosens software strategies technologies
and so on am i up to the task I was
scared to death once I found out in fact
I wanted to go to ten Stanzi on who's
the president of bad labs and say then
can I serve in this job for one week and
then resign so I can tell my kids I
worked at Bell Labs you don't even have
to pay me for that week but I did not
lose my nerve and I've already had been
directions by golly they are really
listening to us we're already observing
a great deal of Technology software
technology and one of my additional
missions is to act as a link between
research universities and Bell Labs
we've already started that we had a
wonderful meeting with Bob Brown Tom
Magnanti was my former colleague the
Dean of engineering now Mike there to
sauce and so on we're moving next to
Harvard it just so happens Harvey
Fineberg because the new Provost was a
dear colleague of mine when I was
teaching at Harvard and we'll move to
Stanford we'll move to Berkeley and we
will bring some of the best ideas into
Bell Labs as an engine of innovation and
my message to Lucent was don't think R&D
I criticize their logo and they took
offense you know marketing people get
very sensitive about lockers I said this
is an O you go round and round and round
and round I said that describes research
and development but I said we're here to
add a second D to take you from research
development and delivery and when you
have our D and D then you have a
powerhouse that's going to transform the
world so on that note I'm counting my
minutes Scott where are you you have to
keep me really honest I have a
reputation of over running sometimes but
I have my word you keep me honest I want
to come to Boston I mentioned I couldn't
get out of Boston Boston in many ways
shaped my life and I think Boston in
many ways has shaped the century and I
want to start with two threads and I
will try to bring them together one is
Alexander Graham Bell the other one is
Alfred P Sloan Alexander Graham Bell I
have an office overlooking the river I
look at the river but I tell you how
many times I look at Back Bay I imagine
Alexander Graham de creating the first
revolution telecommunications revolution
which is telephone mediated we all have
benefited from it but the second
evolution has come to communications and
that is computer mediated communication
revolution see I when I came to MIT I
was just like anyone else enamored with
computers and I thought I was in the hub
of the computer revolution only later on
I realized that no we don't have a
computer revolution we have a computer
mediated communication revolution why
because it's that computer mediated
communication networks that have turned
into knowledge storing networks and I
take pride dr. Bob Ryan's is in the
audience he remembers me in 1969 going
to him with an idea how to connect
millions of computers together without a
central switch and I was almost left out
of Sloan for that because in 1969 that
were going to be five six computing
centers and we were going to time share
my proposal was let's connect millions
of computers together and I got patents
all over the world which I did nothing
with but I'm very happy that the vision
of 1969 has evolved into the knowledge
storing networks of the 1990s I even
went to BBN Bob again will remember he
took me to BBN they said Keenan we don't
have any use for ideas that connect many
many computers together we're just
trying to connect 10 computers together
and how dvn of course claims to have
anyway but what Alexander Graham Bell
spawned he probably didn't know it was
bad Labs and that engine I'm now finding
out really shaped the century each time
I go there and visit the shrine our Bell
Labs
I am surprised to find out that fax
machine was invented at Bell Labs 1925
1925 microphone was invented that
transistor of course we all know was
invented there and it looks like our
lives were shaped by what happened at
Bell Labs but now we come to the second
revolution and I'll come in to Sloan and
connect to to me Bell Labs represents
innovation engineering I think they have
mastered the art of injecting
engineering into innovation and taking
it from sort of a whimsical idea into
something that is cogent that is
dependable that can do something now
slow while I talk Watson I came to Sloan
School in 1961 as an unsuspecting
undergraduate and I was thoroughly
disappointed I would take a course at
Electrical Engineering and marveled at
the cogent see the delivery magnetism
and I'd come back to school of
industrial management this was before
snow there was mass confusion
courses were incoherent we would be
given notes with spelling errors
mathematical errors would have to raise
our hand and correct the instructor I
was very disappointed what I didn't know
was I was witnessing a revolution a true
revolution and I verified it later on
most of you probably don't know that
Harvard followed and still follows the
elites model you bring very bright
students with very bright teachers
together and you make teaching happen
MIT I understood from Howard Johnson and
others that I talked to later on
said we cannot teach management because
management is a set of values but we can
teach management technology and what was
happening at MIT in the early 60s was
pulling management technology together
that's why these guys were confused
because they were writing it as they
were thinking it and we pull students
who are trying to correct them and it
was MIT among others that packaged the
business education and it became
imminently exportable I remember in
1960s our friends in engineering used to
call us money engineers but what they
didn't realize what the world didn't
realize was MIT was inventing business
and organizational engineering by golly
when those two things come together
innovation engineering and business and
organizational engineering it's an
explosive idea it's no wonder that we
exploded the business school population
in the 70s MBA became the golden
education and many places on this earth
could take advantage of thanks to MIT
and thanks to Stanford and Harvard and
so on but MIT I think saw the path
engineer the business process engineer
the organization when people talk of
MBAs I say no we don't hire any MBAs we
hire organizational engineers that's why
I think the American business was
fundamentally transformed because in the
late 70s we had already jumped a hundred
thousand MBAs coming out to change and
so on now I feel truly privileged truly
rewarded because I had the joy of being
a professor for 17 years starting in
1967 as an instructor thrown into the
pores of Sloan fellows Tom Hill told me
do you want to teach Sloan fellow
Skinner I said sure
Tom tell me whom to teach and I'll do my
very best I walked into this classroom
26 years old working on my doctoral
dissertation thin as a needle
and I walked in and no one would pay any
attention to me
and I looked at these guys there's a
bunch of old guys really noisy too so I
said excuse me
the instructor is here I could hear the
pin drop they thought of course I was
the TA what country erase the board well
I learned a great deal from the students
and I immediately declared myself a
student of the subject never the
professor at any rate I think I have
been either rewarded or punished because
after 17 years I was thrust forced into
practicing what I was trying to teach I
can't tell you how exciting it is to
discover how many mistaken thoughts you
taught in the classroom
I felt like sending out recall cards
will you please class of 1972 come back
can i revise that opinion and not only
that but 1984 we recruited as a small
company six MBAs from sloan
organizational engineers and my reward
or punishment was to practice business
with some of my very students and it's a
it's an eye-opener it really is an
eye-opener and we grow the company to
about eight hundred when the merger with
loosen'd happen now I look forward and I
believe I have my true career ahead all
of this was preparation all of this was
really practice I feel like a doctor you
ask them you say what do you do they say
I practice medicine while you say when
are you really going to learn it should
I really trust you if you were just
practicing it and and so on and I feel
in a genuine sense Here I am 58 years
old and every year I have been
practicing for what is ahead which is to
bring innovation engineering as is the
case at Bell Labs together with
organizational and business engineering
to push ahead and be a change factor
inside loosened and help transform
loosened into the software company of
the next decade and for me that's what
entrepreneurship is all about when I was
asked many times what is
entrepreneurship I never viewed it as
making money but I viewed it as creating
value for others I never viewed it as
competing with that guy out there kill
him so that you can capture the market I
think that's a war analogy that's a
sports analogy a much better analogy for
entrepreneurship is the nurturing
creation giving birth to something that
others had not been able to yet or
haven't got around to and really
expanding the pie for everyone to take
part in how am i doing my yeah I have
two or three more minutes to take some
questions so that's why I really feel
truly honored privileged I feel like a
kid I I wish someone in my 20s had told
me that at age 58 I would be just as
energetic as enthusiastic as I was at 28
I wouldn't have rushed so much
how were they taken some time and
enjoyed the wonder of halls of MIT and
absorbed much more knowledge would have
become much more of a student so I will
tell you young entrepreneurs the spirit
of entrepreneurship which is the ability
and the opportunity to expand the value
on the school just doesn't seem to end
just doesn't seem to end so don't rush
take your time change it and enjoy let
me stop and see if you have one or two
questions I promised Scott that I would
end on time even with questions yes
please
oh I've had many mentors I've had many
mentors I have my during the recent
years my most important mentor was
Howard Johnson he was my Dean and then
of course he became the president of MIT
after we had given him a go away gift he
came back on the way to Cincinnati and
the dorm I think was a painted orange
because people thought Howard Johnson
Howard Johnson they made a confusion and
when the company got going in 19 really
got going in 86 85 having observed the
presence of many small companies and
having concluded that presence of small
companies are very dangerous people they
can cause a lot of hurt tell other
people I was determined I wouldn't do
that so I turned our Johnson I said
Howard would you please come and join
the board because you can tell me to go
to hell if you do I really will try to
find a path to help and he'd been
wonderful and he said I have one
condition King I will bring Jerry
Wiesner with me Jerry Wiesner was
Canada's science advisor and the
subsequent president I said Howard if
you bring Jerry I will feel like a
student but when I went to see Jerry
Wiesner who became a very excellent
mentor I hate to stop myself because I
was apologizing to Jerry Wiesner
I said dr. wizard I promise I won't take
you take much of your time
and dr. wisdom simultaneously was saying
Keenan I have been out of technology for
a long time I don't know if I'm worthy
of being a board member and I had to
bite my tongue and stop and I was
patronizing a great mentor when he was
teaching me humility he was teaching me
listening he was a great mentor and I
acknowledge it Robert Scheer Edie and I
go way back
it goes back to 1957 by the way I reveal
some of the secrets but Edie has never
lost the entrepreneurial spirit either
EDI we were neighbors
we were colleagues I was a student when
he was a faculty member
I can name bill pounds I can name a
whole lot of my professors so I have
been very fortunate to have a lot of
mentors but the most unexpected mentors
were the students I can't tell you how
much I learned from the students and in
the company I still go to them and ask
their you know coaching and I've
converted that to the following a
philosophy that the the most fundamental
role of a manager is to make other
people succeed not ask them to make him
sorry but if you look at many places
people say these are my direct reports
and these are your objectives this is
how you're going to make me sighs when
you try to make others succeed it's
amazing how much you succeed - anyway
that's a long answer to a short question
yes please
well they actually did get it
interesting enough because as part of
this arrangement which was very exciting
negotiations and this and that
everybody got Lucent options in fact
some of the key people got enough
options that they will be better off
than if we had gone public and I'm very
happy about that but way back when when
people were coming to us and our
recruiting record has been excellent I
was very honest we're open with them I
said you will not get any equity for a
very simple reason we're not in this
business to make money but to apply the
money we make to make a difference
if that's what you want this is the
company if you want to make money here's
how you can make money will pay you
above market you take the difference and
invest it in a company that most likely
will make a lot of money and I can't
tell you how many people responded to
that in fact one person came back and
said I discusses with my wife my wife
said that's really astute advice why
would you want to take two chances on
the same company for your salary and
also for your future seller
many times companies don't give equity
and on top of that pay above market the
reality is one expects the market to
make up to difference that's a good
model I'm not knocking a ton but the
alternative model also works because
there are plenty of people who want to
get a good pay take a portion of it and
invest and work to make a difference
rather than to make a lot of money it's
different model so that's how I
responded and a lot of people responded
to that any other thank you very much
[Applause]
well I'd like to thank dr. Sahin for 10
years we've been talking about the
philosophy of the 50k as bringing
together engineering science and
management to create great results and
change the world and I don't think any
of us has ever said it as well as that
so thank you very much it's people like
this and all of you who really make this
a great job that I've had for a year and
this is the moment where I turned that
job over to next year's lead organizer
Heather Wilding who will come up and
take over the rest of the presentation
for tonight so please join me in
welcoming her and wishing her best of
luck for the next year
we have now reached the part of the
evening where we will hear from the
seven finalists teams the seven finalist
teams our adventure Bazaar calm
Crossgate a dental calm just enzyme
molecular aware vector sense and z2
corporation we will proceed through the
finalists presentations in alphabetical
order and each team will receive ten
minutes adventure bizarre calm
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen wear sunscreen if I
could offer you only one tip for the
future sunscreen would be it if I could
offer you two tips for the future
invest in adventure bizarre calm the
long-term benefits of sunscreen have
been proven by scientists whereas the
long-term viability of Internet
companies hasn't been proven by anyone
well we feel pretty good about our idea
so who are we my name is Chris Morrison
with me or the other founding members
Osmond boner Tim Frederick and Irene
tunkel the four of us have met here at
the Sloan School of Management we're all
pursuing MBA I'm sorry organizational
engineering degrees we come from various
backgrounds from consultant to a design
engineer the project manager to even a
banker we are bound together by a love
for adventure travel so what is
adventure bizarre calm venture bizarre
calm is an online a travel agency that
caters to adventure travelers we operate
through a community centric website we
provide pura for information and
one-stop shopping for our customers but
what's the heart and soul of our company
what makes us different well we're a
community not a company basically all
four of us have done adventure travel
anyone you talk to is done adventure
travel is extremely enthusiastic about
this whenever you talk to someone who's
extremely into kayaking they will keep
you up all night telling you everything
they know about kayaking we want to tap
into this enthusiasm we want to create a
reliable up-to-date database we want to
use this database to harness everyone's
information that they have about this to
consolidate the industry we want to
provide up-to-date information and use
this to aid in the planning and purchase
of adventure travel actually there is a
great market for adventure travel
especially for the adventure travel
online travel agency currently online
travel sales constitute as much as 40%
of all online e-commerce revenue but
this number is going to reach 7 billion
by the end of 2001 as for the adventure
travel it is the fastest growing segment
of all the travel industry it grows by
as much as 25% per year
and over the past five years more than
92 million Americans have taken an
adventure travel vacation so who are
these adventure travelers who are the
main players in this market
well of course adventure travelers and
adventure service providers adventure
travelers adventuresome people who like
to take active vacation they pursue such
activities as kayaking a mountain biking
whitewater rafting and they go to the
most remote remote corners of the world
currently it's extremely difficult to
plan an adventure vacation it's hard to
find guides it is difficult to make all
the travel arrangements as for the
adventure travel providers they are
scattered all around the world and they
don't have resources to reach the
customers what adventure bazaar will do
it will bring all these players together
we will create a virtual meeting place
for doing two travel providers and
adventure travelers and we will make
adventure travel planning much easier so
the services we plan to offer for
adventure travelers consists as Irena
pointed out consolidation of planning as
she said that it's very difficult to
plan at a venture travel vacation it
takes a lot of time and a lot of
research and conventional means like
guidebooks and websites and things like
this we plan to provide not only access
to adventure travel services but
conventional services as well through
conventional databases such as Sabre we
plan a consolidation of information
through the community that Chris talked
about a consolidation of information
things like travel logs and discussion
groups a place where adventure travelers
can meet and find out about new places
to go and new things to do in addition
to that kind of freeform pictures and
text kind of information that they can
delve into we plan to consolidate the
information in a custom rating system
similar to as Zagat's except for
adventure travel where Zagat's rates
business or sorry restaurants all around
the world we will provide the same kind
of easy to use easy to index easy to
search
ratings for adventure travel service
providers every traveler that books with
us will offer also receive complimentary
travel certain services for instance a
individually designed packet containing
information about their specific trip
things that they need to know sometimes
months in advance
things like shots that they'll need
documentation that they'll need the
political climate of the places they're
visiting emergency numbers and who to
contact during their trip on the other
side we offer also offer services for
adventure travel service providers these
are our these are also customers but
they're also our suppliers they're the
product that we'll be booking through
this site like I said booking services
will be offering payment collection
services advertising for them these are
services that don't have a lot of
resources that don't have a lot of ways
to reach the customer in the United
States and all over the world that they
need to contact these things and others
Wilkinson's will create a constellation
of business management tools for these
companies to better plan and smooth
their business when it comes to earning
money that wasn't a silence we know how
to earn money when it comes to earning
money we'd like to follow the path of a
traditional travel agency we'd like to
charge Commission's on brooked travels
however we've identified one point which
can work against our strategy and that
is charging for our websites well we're
not going to charge it's gonna be free
for any user on the web it's going to be
everybody is going to be able to enter
it and we've identified two main reasons
for not charging firstly are as we've
explained before our suppliers is our
customers so they build our content and
we can't discourage them to come coming
from to come to the site and number two
as a reason we want to use our customers
as advertisers we believe the word of
mouth will be the main promotion channel
for our website
well is this big business gonna be
sustainable that's a question well on
our strategy we've identified three main
core competencies firstly we believe
that community and the content we create
will be difficult to replicate secondly
as a brand name we want to promote a
reliable and objective information
content provider and as a third on the
operation front we want to build
supplier relationships that will not be
replicated or if so we'll be very time
costly and also costly to replicate in
conclusion I would like to say we are
we're just not that not only just
another dot-com company we have
identified top 5 reasons why we don't
fall in this category
firstly we're not simply it bricks and
mortar company that has moved its
operations into the internet we are not
amazon.com we are not Barnes and
noble.com we seed Internet to be our
central issue if the internet doesn't
exist we cannot bring all these
fragmented players together into a
virtual markets as a reason number four
who aim not to have a capitalisation as
low as high as Russia as number three
and we actually aim to make a profit and
we aim to make this profit without
selling pornography yes that's a good
note and finally or perhaps first we'd
like to we don't even have a clue how to
spell IPO thank you
[Applause]
Thank You adventure bazaar calm we will
now hear from Crossgate
[Applause]
[Music]
what can you do with these you can ski
in the summer at Ski Areas you can carve
turns just like you would on downhill
skis you can go on your favorite
mountain biking trails you can go fast
downhill and you can go up hill terrain
is no problem first of all I'd like to
introduce our team this is Sam Hartwell
Sam has two years of CEO experience at
best Minh green systems a bio
engineering firm and he has an MBA from
Yale this is my brother Matt page Matt
helped develop the core technology of
the Crossgate and he's currently a
master's candidate in product design at
MIT and this is huge Akeem Shuja has
experience as a financial analyst at
Morgan Stanley Dean Witter and he's
currently a bachelor's candidate at MIT
Sloan School of Management and I'm James
page the founder and president of
Crossgate and my relevant experience is
that I started a product design company
in Silicon Valley where I worked on a
number of sporting goods products
including one called the free board
which is a hybrid skateboard snowboard
and it was that experience that helped
me realize the opportunity for Crossgate
and helped bring it to life at this
point we're going to tell you more about
the market the outdoor sports market is
filled with examples of crossovers
between summer and winter sports for
example inline skating was really
invented as a way for ice skaters to
skate in the summertime and snowboarding
a very popular sport was conceived as a
way to surf the mountains
but there really isn't a way to ski to
downhill ski in the summertime where
would you go if you wanted to ski in the
summertime maybe Chile New Zealand Yeah
right maybe some of you V seas out there
what this is this is the poor man's
ticket to Chile and New Zealand alright
next slide we've had over 50 users test
our product and they all loved it
downhill skiers particularly liked it
because it emulated the motion and the
excitement and the challenge of downhill
skiing but we recognize that our market
is made up of at least three overlapping
larger markets unlike other crossover
markets we expect the growth of the
market that we've targeted will outpace
that of its parent markets now that
we've talked about the market that we're
identifying Matt's gonna explain how the
product works thank you okay so I
imagine we probably have a lot of
mountain bikers and downhill skiers out
there yes
good very good so as Jamie was saying
the best thing about the Crossgate is
that you can use it on all your favorite
hiking trails and at your favorite
downhill skiing areas in the summer time
and you can carve turns just like
downhill skiing you can do that through
our terrific steering technology now I'd
also like to point out that these wheels
are a lot larger than rollerblade wheels
let's say and what this helps you do is
just carve these turns and take this
terrain with the best of them I mean no
holds barred anything goes with this
stuff right also our skates are quite a
bit longer than any of our competition
this gives us a lot more stability you
can go anywhere do anything these are
terrific and then lastly we've got a
mechanism that doesn't let you roll
backwards so you can actually go uphill
as well as downhill and it's no problem
now turn it back over to Jamie he's
going to tell you a little bit more
about sales and operations oK we've
identified our target market as being
outdoor enthusiasts and our early
adopter market is going to be the most
hardcore outdoor enthusiasts where do
they hang out ski areas so our sales and
marketing effort focuses around ski
areas first of all in order to get
publicity we're going to employ a co
marketing effort with the ski areas
whereby they will promote the product
both winter and summer in the winter
time all the ski areas of all the skiers
are there so they'll be seeing videos
and other promotional events there and
they'll follow up in the summertime with
demos and rentals so you can try them
out there it's important to note that
over 200 skiers are open in the
summertime for mountain biking already
in an effort for them to try to create
summer revenues but they're still really
hungry for another sport to create those
revenues we'll follow that up that
promotion with information kits a great
video and then thirdly we've identified
that it's very important for people to
try this product in order to create
sales and to try it again at Ski Areas I
people can go and try it in the summer
and then also we'll have a retina work
set set up across the country so the
people can try it out even when they're
not at a ski area and then finally the
good part
what everyone wants to hear sales the
way we create sales is initially direct
with with some of the money going to the
ski areas and then also some of the
money going to the reps when sales are
made through reps and then we will
transition to selective retail
distribution so that's the summary of
our our sales plan and it's important to
note that this is based off of a proven
model that has been used by companies
such as line ski boards which pioneered
the new sport of skiing and the next
thing I'm going to tell you about is our
operations model as you can tell we're
based on a manufacturing business model
and just a couple of quick points is
that we're going to start out doing
manufacturing in-house so that we're
quick on our toes and we can stay ahead
of the competition make quick design
changes and then we will move towards
outsourcing as it makes financial sense
to do so
finally we already have a manufacturing
facility set up in the Northampton
Massachusetts area with a full machine
shop and we're ready to go I liked it I
liked you guys close your eyes and think
about the time when you learned how to
skate well that product is no longer in
the market the new trend or rather an
intermediary trend is rollerblading yes
it is an intermediate Ori trend because
soon the future is cross skating and
what will it take to bring these new
cool products into the market well we're
asking for 1 million dollars in two
stages of funding we project our
five-year unit sales to be over 40,000
selling at 399 apiece a sales revenue is
over 18 million by year 5 a break-even
point is about 5,000 units so this this
initial round of funding of mundane
dollars we asked for 500 500 thousand
dollars in June of 1999 and upon
completion of our milestones namely
matching our sales projections adopt
getting a ski resource to adopt a
product and acquiring new clients
we'd ask for another round of funding in
July of 2000 well if you can't afford to
go skiing during the summer and chilly
goodbye cross kids if you're afraid of
rollerblading and being run over by a
car like me we buy Crossgates and if you
want the latest thrilled in downhill
skiing you'd buy cross gates with that
I'd like to conclude my presentation
today and just to let you know we will
have the cross skates available after
the ceremonies tonight
so that you can try them on thank you
[Applause]